gene herschel was an actor director
writer whose legacy of philanthropy
immortalized his place in cinema history
as the man who gave hollywood his
conscience
in our business many of us leave home
and travel for pleasant work or
we're often wrapped up in filming on
location or busy promoting our projects
we don't always seize the advantage to
immerse ourselves in the places the
people we encounter
through her travels angelina jolie has
taken full advantage of her experiences
to listen
to learn to change her worldview
i met angelina a long time ago
because my daughter
who was i think about 10 at the time
was a huge angelina jolie fan
primarily because of her work and
because of her humanity and um because
we're fighting for what is right
my daughter at 10 was very idealistic
and
a lot of angelina's values had rubbed
off on her
and so
i asked her if she would have lunch with
my daughter and she said sure
and
at that point we sat down and we were
talking and going over things and she
adopted a son and i'd adopted
three children by myself so we were two
basically single parents talking about
children
and
i said
uh
you know children are the pathway to a
compassionate life into happiness and
this is the one true thing you can do is
have children
little that i know she'd take me so
seriously
and not only has she
got a wonderful family but she has done
so much for children around the world
i would expect
uh ultimately that she's probably
hopefully the happiest person in the
world
because she definitely has
a lot of the compassion
she has taken this knowledge to a bigger
place
uh she has worked diligently to make us
aware to compel us to take action
through her storytelling on behalf of
the un
she has opened our eyes to violence to
victimization in sierra leone
tanzania pakistan cambodia ecuador and
rwanda and i'm sure it'll be in many
other places through her storytelling on
film she has depicted the horrors of war
and used her art to illuminate justice
issues and make positive changes in the
world
she's currently filming a true life
account of hope and resilience
and through her passion to tell such
compelling stories on the screen through
her work in washington and around the
globe angelina has come to embody that
conscience associated with gene herschel
and it gives me great pleasure to
present the academy of motion pictures
arts and sciences gene herschel award to
an artist whose humanitarian efforts
continue to touch and inspire the world
angelina jolie
[Applause]